le vatican a une structure
en me fais pas ça
les atomes de carbone que les formes les
fugues et et prendre des examens ne peut
prétendre à bidart et une adresse du
carbone et du graphite
c'est sa capacité en fait deux d'abord
des plantes liste très classique ou un
portable et c'est pour ce faire d
utiliser dans les nids des crayons à
papier et là j'ai pris un bon ce parti
que j'ai rappelé devant laboratoire
heures démonstration
sa dernière escale à nantes a donc pour
plus son utilisation commune dans les
mines de crayon papier de graphie à
cette propriété en fait d'avoir des
enfants qui peut s'arracher les années
dans cette interview il a ajouté une
deuxième façon de faire se rencontrer
voilà je prends mon trafic lui colle un
morceau de scotch comme ça et là
j'arrache longue favl bon sens des
images très facilement et c'est
s'approprier verts eelv à la passe lavez
vous les mains - nouveau loin de la
politique
en effet en septembre
les motards ou peut assurer un certain
dans un puits dont du lithium c'est sa
fonction deux délits semaine à rome et
donc profité de l'épreuve au aluminium
c'est le troisième élément de la
classification périodique
c'est le médecin le plus léger sur terre
les plus légers floor
il est pour ça vraiment 2000 quand il
était libre
mieux le lithium
on ne trouve essentiellement dans un
certain sens de roche mais aussi en
amérique latine en particulier en
argentine au mobilier au chili sur des
lacs salés pour l'appel salinas il se
trouve à des altitudes entre 1500 m
s'est levé pour cesser ses mac salle est
trop vieille et océans il ya plusieurs
centaines d'années qui se sont retirés
ils vont baisser d épaisseur et de
lumière de l'eau celle du salon musée
mais ils ont la particularité de gens là
il y en a aussi au tibet quand on
regarde les quatre pays dont je viens de
parler il regroupe il renferme environ
80% des réserves mondiale du lithium et
je vais vous dire après qu en fait celui
qui au delà il est con vraiment très
très disponible pour alors l'autre chose
c'est que dans une batterie au lithium
dans le schéma est représentée ici
l'anode le pôle négatif et la cathode le
pôle positif qu'on tienne cet élément et
c'est la circulation des ions lithium
qui sont représentés par des billes
rouges qui ont qui en se déplaçant entre
l'anode et la cathode qui font que
finalement la batterie se décharge et
que vous avez un courant électrique à
l'intérieur de votre votre téléphone
quand j'avais commencé ma thèse de
doctorat à l'institut nations plus
technique de grenoble et centres
nationaux de la recherche scientifique
les piles au lithium existaient déjà et
par rapport aux piles alcalines et
salines qui sont très très connu elle
permettait
et de stocker trois fois plus d'énergie
c'est-à-dire qu'elle permettait de faire
fonctionner un appareil que certains
d'entre vous dont certains d'entre vous
se souviennent
le walkman trois fois plus longtemps et
parce que le lithium est très léger et
qui permet effectivement d'avoir cette
énergie plus importante que les gens ont
commencé à réfléchir peut-on
confectionner la pala la copie
rechargeable sur une batterie à base de
lithium et ça a été un grand challenge
dans les fin des années 70 début des
années 80 on a essayé beaucoup de
formules rien au marché et c'est là
qu'un jour on me réveillant je sais pas
pour que pour quelle raison il ya eu une
inspiration comme ça et je me suis dit
tiens je vais faire une expérience qui a
été l'arrêt l'expérience déterminante de
ma vie voici la cellule alors je sais
pas si ça vous dit quelque chose c'est
une batterie sauf que vous pouvez pas
l'excusé dans un téléphone portable
mais cette batterie la a rempli sa
mission à savoir
elle m'a permis de rentrer de stocker du
lithium à l'intérieur du graphite
grâce à ce qu'on appelle un électrolyte
solide alors que tous les gens qui
travaillaient avant sur ce sujet-là
utilisaient des électrolyte liquide et
ça ne marchait pas donc le changement
que les kids solide a permis de réaliser
cette électrode et là je vais vous
montrer une vidéo qui a été réalisé par
un collègue à moi aux états unis et qui
reproduit exactement ce que moi aussi
j'avais observé entre à la fin des
années 70 début des années 80 voilà donc
ça c'est une électrode en carbone au
départ noirs et là le lithium comme va
commencer à rentrer par le bas et 20 se
prolonge et regarder ce qui se passe là
changement de couleur voilà à la fin de
l'opération c'est à dire quand le
lithium se rend dans le graphite
on a un objet doré complètement doré et
quand le diction brossard du graphite
eh bien le
le graphique reprend sa couleur initiale
noir et c'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de votre batterie à chaque
fois que vous la charge et si vous aviez
la possibilité de regarder ce qui se
passe
vous verriez ce changement de couleur
qui se répètent des centaines et des
milliers de fois dans les téléphones
portables des ordinateurs portables
quand je pense que mon électrodes en
graphite fait partie de la batterie qui
alimente le ce robot de la nasa
opportunity et qui lui a permis d'une
part de parcourir une distance record de
tout objet sur une planète du système
solaire à savoir 42000 195 km la
longueur d'un marathon d'accord et qui a
duré onze ans la mission d'opportunités
davin a duré onze ans alors que les
spécialistes de la nasa avait estimé la
durée de la mission à quatre mois et
cette durée exceptionnelle vient
justement de la lance d'utilité des
batteries au lithium
alors
vous avez certainement suivi la fin de
l'année dernière en novembre
l'atterrissage de dan orbite d'un objet
et un dada système de la deûle agence
européenne de l'espace sur la comète
souris il s'appelle phil ivey filet
s'est posé sur souris après avoir
parcouru 500 millions de kilomètres en
dix ans et il a réussi à se poser et
tout le guidage tout le délai de la
dernière phase de l'atterrissage a été
permise grâce à une pile et une batterie
au lithium donc ça me ça m'émeut
d'une certaine manière de savoir que les
petites inventions comme ça et à voyager
aussi loin dans l'espace et permet
justement de de faire des choses
absolument impensable que d'explorer des
comètes alors le grand challenge
maintenant on le grand défi du 21e
siècle c'est le réchauffement climatique
et la pollution atmosphérique
ces problèmes là sont vraiment très très
sérieux dans le sens où si les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et des
particules fines continue au rythme
actuel est bien la température du globe
augmentera de 4 degrés ou de plus de 4
degrés d'ici 2100
cela provoquera un certain nombre de
catastrophes naturelles en particulier
la montée des niveaux de niveau de l'eau
des océans de d'environ 1 ou 2 mètres ce
qui va obliger à déplacer des millions
et des millions de personnes
d'une part d'autre part ça va augmenter
le nombre de phénomènes climatiques
extrêmes les
les ouragans les la sécheresse les
inondations et en plus la pollution
augmente justement ce type de choses
c'est à dire les jeunes et les plus les
personnes les plus vulnérables qui
attrapent des problèmes qui ont des
problèmes respiratoires
donc il faut absolument faire quelque
chose pour sauver la planète et ça ça
passe en fait par le changement radical
de la manière dont on utilise l'énergie
or nous avons une énergie absolument
infini à base de soleil et à passe
devant ya pas de la base de vagues
et si on exploite ses sources d'énergie
inépuisable et durable eh bien ça
permettra petit à petit justement à
réduire les gaz à effet de serre et
aussi la pollution dans les villes donc
rêvons d'un monde un peu plus propre
grâce au lithium
pourquoi le lithium parce qu'en fait ces
énergies là ne sont pas disponibles 24
heures sur 24
donc il faut les stocker et c'est là que
les batteries au lithium vont avoir à
jouer un rôle central entre la
production de l'énergie et sa
consommation
donc je rêve de voir ça un peu partout
dans les villes du maroc est un peu
partout dans le monde des voitures
électriques qui sont silencieuses qui
permet en fait non seulement de de ne
pas polluer mais aussi de faire des
économies parce que le kilomètre le prix
qu'on paie pour travaux pour voyager 1
km revient moins cher quand c'est
électrique
il ya autre chose qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
c'est ces animaux là j'aimerais pas de
voir disparaître
merci beaucoup